hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the banter blitz club
it's the semi-finals and it's Ally
resolution vs. and Narayanan and a funny
short story before we check out the game
I already recorded this video and almost
started uploading it but then I realized
that I mixed up the players as there are
two Indian grandmasters by the name of
neuron I I recorded the video using a
profile photo of the wrong one as I
didn't know how the gentleman looks like
and then when I checked III saw oh yeah
never even crossed my mind that there
could be two of them with the same name
but now I'm recording it so let's dive
straight into it once again so reza
opens with efore and it's very rare that
i will redo a video pretty much
regardless of the mistake I make so so
this is one of the well one of the
examples where I will do so and sorry
about that
yeah we have E for byali Reza and c5 the
Sicilian defense is on the board we have
93 d6 and now just a nice trade in the
center as they usually do Knight of six
Knight to c3 and a6 the knight of
variation is on the board we have Bishop
to g5 e 6 and f4 and here Queen to b6 so
all standard stuff going after the pawn
here and the Queen to d2 is very popular
here going into the poisoned pawn
variation but Alireza probably decided
that since he goes Queen b6 of course he
is well versed in the Lions of the
poisoned pawn so he just defends at
night to b3
we have Knight B to d7 and now quinta e
2 preparing to Castle queenside also be
5 might be an idea in the future so
Queen to c7 gaining more control over
the e5 square but also getting the Queen
away from the beep B file so you can
start pushing with b5 we have queenside
castle and now b5 right away now with a
3 for the moment stopping before and the
best of the e7 just a continuing
development g4 and now fallujah
continues to push on the King side and
rook the b8
look Toby it is a very exciting move
because this is a three minute
blitz game three plus two I like all the
games are in the Bandra blitz Cup but
this position has been reached in 2018
between Alexander Greece you can machine
wash allograft in the Isle of Man
tournament where h6 was played by by mvl
and the Grisha panini Bishop to h4 and
Grisha was able to win that game so look
the B it is in fact an improvement on
that game
it's the engines top recommendation so
Narayanan really knows his stuff how to
play against white here with the strip
the h4 now preparing to shift the bishop
over to this diagonal which will at some
point help out with the pushing of the
e5 pawn and also might have ideas of
dislodging the night with g5 so here
there is one game where b4 was played
but here we have h6 and it is now as
I've moved 13 that we have a completely
new game so Bishop to g3 not allowing g5
to come with a double attack here now
preparing to e5 and now B for opening up
the B file a captures rook captures and
now Bishop the g2 putting the bishop on
this diagonal black does the same once
the counter white bishop and now h4 just
continuing to push on the King side
Knights the c5 of course you have to
capture because black will just capture
on b3 and grab a pawn so Knight captures
we have D captures and now finally he
five and this is already one of the
critical moments in the game where the
knight is attacking obviously there is
this tension between the bishops so
tonight the d5 here is the way to go for
black however it's hard to decide on
everything when you were well when it's
a three minute blitz games so nice the
d7 was played and this is always very
exciting when you have this insane
preparation like that rook to b8 move
with an improvement and Grishka MVL game
and then you employ such preparation in
a three minute Blitz game and then at
some point when you run out of
preparation all hell will break loose
it's it's always like that
so here knight retreats the d7 but now
f5 really awesome stuff because now
characters is met with
six and now this really really comes
alive as now everything is just a a
problem here if Queen captures Bishop
then you capture the night with check
and now after King to date you also grab
the lights where the shop so after rook
captures on b7 now you have rook H 2 e1
and it's just just a disgusting position
to play there's really not not much you
can do here Queen captures Bishop is
coming and of course the bishop cannot
move if you move the bishop then of
course it's just the deadly Quinta e8
and that's that's just it captures
captures the Queen comes into the game
and it's just over so after f5 we have
Queen to a5 now shifting the Queen to
the Queen side maybe some Queen a1
action can be possible in the future and
okay Bishop character sin b7 and now
rook captures on b7 however there is
also the possibility of Queen to a one
check but white always comes out on top
for example King B - you're gonna
capture here and now white would have to
find Queen f3 there's the threat yes
okay there's you could capture the
bishop but you don't you never want to
do that because we just wrote b1 so the
real threat is here look the d4 trick
followed by Queen captures the knight so
we have to play Queen f3 and now white
just defended everything and white is
fine Ruby d4 trick can be met with King
you want and you are defending the
knight and that this will always be met
with just Ruby 1 and black is just lost
once you move the Queen you lose the
rook and that's that's it
so after the bishop character Sam b7 we
have rook recapturing Bishop on b7 and
now fallujah continues opening up the
position F captures an e6 black has to
recapture there's nothing better and now
a beautiful centralizing more Queenie 4
with a double attack here on the rook on
b7 and also on the g6 square
yes it's maybe I've raised a bit funny
attack the g6 square but you are
threatening a deliverer check here and
pick up the e6 pawn or maybe the g7 bond
all depends on how the situation changes
and here quinta b6 is best for black it
attacks the B to pawn while defending
the exponent however in Iran and why
for Queen to b4 check he doesn't seem to
mind this pong rabbit and he says that
if you go for that pong Reb then I will
also have threats of my own so ali reza
goes for queen g6 check King d8 and he
grabs the pawn now there's a lot of
pressure on the night here for the
moment is defended but you know the king
is still on a very uncomfortable a
square and file so Queen captures on
beat you with check King to d2 and now
again rube before with the idea of rook
to d4 check picking of the night and
well hopefully winning the game and now
Bishop to f2 blocking the d4 square and
here instead of Bishop to f2 nights to
eat you with a little bit better since
this allows black bring the rook into
the game with with tempo as it comes
with an attack on the bishop so here
Bishop to e3 was played by fuchsia and
now rook to f3 rook to f3 was played
with the idea of rook captures Bishop
fall by Queen captures night here
just grabbing two pieces for a look
however rook to f3 doesn't work it it's
a losing move but there is one game that
there's one move that's really the best
move for black and it's basically
forcing a draw on the spot so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this absolute best move for black while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on supporting that this
is the only way to continue the game for
black as otherwise the white will be
better and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's still a rogue d4
check now point is after Bishop
characters captures there's the well the
threat of just capturing you tonight so
95 going after the bishop here but now
Bishop to b4 with Czech Knight captures
and now finally rook to f2 with check
King Teti one and now Quintus III check
giving up a rook and now forcing a
perpetual after Queen e3 wherever you go
the Queen will be able to check the
White King and it's always going to be a
perpetual check check and goes here you
check here King goes here you just
repeat if you go here you check here if
you go here check here and there's no
escape but impossible of course
that this bought this in in a
three-minute Birds game and also it you
immediately see that it doesn't yield
anything better than a draw and of
course maybe in Iran and was looking for
a way to win so instead he played rook
to f3 with the idea of rook captures
Bishop but that's just the thing here
I'm not gonna ask you to pause the video
because it's well it would be a bit too
much but here rook to three losses
immediately the king eat you it's funny
but you know such things happen in just
because you've now opened up an attack
here you're threatening checkmate
and you're also threatening to pick up
the rook and blacks initial idea of
chakras captures and captures doesn't
work because of rook d3
now again you either lose the Queen or
its mate so that would be that would
have been it for the game if King to eat
you was played really an amazing move
but ali reza went for ninety five again
going for the bishop here and now
nar-anon goes for rook to d4 with check
and you cannot capture the rook if you
capture then Queen captures and again
you reach this perpetual where the white
king is just stuck going back and forth
if you go of course they eat you you're
getting checkmated Queens you have two
will be checkmate
so after Luke d4 check King Ichi was
played but now Narayanan has to continue
happily sacrificing material will rook
captures here on f3 III Knight captures
at least you've brought one of the
attackers back and now Queen tab e5 with
track King back to f2 and now Queen to
b7
now the queen is ready to help out with
the defense and ready to meet Knight to
d5 Knight to d5 is strongest here but
fallujah I decided against it because
here yes you can defend okay this is now
attacking e7 Knight f8 this was the idea
behind the Queen b7 now the bishop is
defended but you can just trade
everything and go into a nice winning
endgame here rook captures pawn captures
in it's a look against a knight would be
winning for white but fallujah decides
to go for a different plan
Queen f5 now threatens east 6 the get
the panel all the way to e6 we have
Queen to b4 now
Retin in Queen rook to afford to pick up
the Queen as it will come with Chuck so
king of three not allowing it in the
Queen to see three now and here Felicia
says okay Rudy three let's trade
as I'm up the exchange so I don't mind
trading or you go back so Quinta five
Queen to a5 not on now of course doesn't
want to trade and now rook H to d1
doubling up on the D file Queen b6
supporting d4 once again and now future
trades once rook captures see captures
and finally II 6 and here the point is
you cannot capture here because of just
rook characters here and then well we
can even show it if characters then
captures if King goes here then Queen to
f7 is checkmate if you go here then you
just lose the piece and it's game over
so after each six Knight to f6 was
played but now comes again ninety five
again offering trades which are of
course not not in in Black's favor
so Queen the c6 pinning the night and
now comes route characters on b4 so
Bishop c5 pushing the rook back route
back to d3 and now King Teti ed you have
to you have to get out of this nasty pin
because there are a lot of nasty
discoveries here you might lose your
queen
so King to e8 and now c4 and it's a just
a beautiful move cementing that night
and b5 not much black can do about this
any trades are of course in White's
favor so not much point in doing that if
you try this then even Queen to f7 is
just there looking goes here you can
capture here with check in to see it
east 7 is coming with with a 8 just
crushing so after c4 Queen the a4 was
played but as time is running low on the
clock there is not much to do a fuchsia
ended this game very swiftly with Queen
to g6 check and now of course if you go
if you go to D file than any Knight
check towards the Queen will pick off
the Queen so not much point in doing
that so not Ireland decided to walk in
to mate with King to a fate and future
deliver checkmate with Queen to f7 so
the mate is on the board and we have
this really really beautiful beautiful
game and it's often the case
you have such well extreme engine
preparation thrown in a 3-minute blitz
game then when both players run out of
preparation then just everything goes
crazy and those are the best kinds of
games so that's the first game of the
match a lot we have suggested this one
that's why I showed this one and the
match ended 9 to 6 in the favor of
fallujah so future will be facing Magnus
Carlsen in the finals of the Metro blitz
Cup and the Magnus Carlsen predicted it
he said that Narayan has been playing
incredibly well but that it will be
really really difficult to overcome
future so he did expect Volusia to win
and now 2 of them will be in the finals
if you remember our course undefeated
assignments you go in in the semi finals
with a with a score of 9 to 0 which is
just crazy so in these times of lockdown
where not much is going on in the world
such a match is definitely to be
promoted Crossman versus Fallujah is
gonna be really awesome probably gonna
cover more than one game from that match
but but we'll see how it goes so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Douglas Prince
Johnny Olsen Shai gross a joke human
Roth and Matthew Finn for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day